all right well we have scored with some
beautiful snow in the mountains this
week but it is so cold up there
temperatures in the teens right now up
at lee canyon and kyle canyon but things
will eventually warm up valley
temperatures in the 30's so kids warm
jackets we are sunny and cold the
afternoon will be a little bit warmer
today we're looking to be in those mid
to uh mid to upper 50s a nice sunshine
though and that's that's the big bonus
is we've got good sunshine to finish the
week and to slide into the weekend with
sunny skies as well days are getting a
little bit longer so that gives us
slightly more time to warm up a little
bit but not not enough we're not getting
back to normal just yet lots of 30s near
freezing in many neighborhoods even some
20s in the south valley right now out at
red rock prump you're in the 20s
mesquite in the 20s near freezing in
boulder city there's a lot to sneeze
about and that's because ash elm and
juniper still blooming out there and not
only those trees but also you know the
ornamental trees that a lot of
neighborhoods have planted like these
beautiful flowering pear trees these
don't bear fruit but boy when we get
into february and then march but you see
all these gorgeous trees just start
popping out with gorgeous flowers and
you'll probably you're probably seeing
these in your neighborhood or at least
nearby and those will continue to bloom
here over the next several weeks as we
head towards spring and a lot of folks
are allergic to them so take your
antihistamines the west nice and clear
super cold over the northern plains and
the midwest and that cold air is pushing
this rain and turning it into snow and
freezing rain across the northeast where
they were in the 60s in new york they're
freezing this morning and a lot of
flights have been canceled because of
that cold and because of the bad weather
so just check your flights if you're
headed east of the rockies today could
be cancelled or at least delayed lots of
cold will stay put for us for now 36 on
the mountain for the high today and
again mid to upper 50s for the valley we
should be in the mid 60s for the last
few days of february and we really won't
make it until maybe sunday definitely
monday as we jump into warmer 70s and
even upper 70s our first few days of
march that's quite a warm-up with a
ridge that will build quickly next week
and then it will drop again as another
system comes in at the end of the week